According to the World Health organization,
Roughly 800,000 people commit suicide every year along with many more suicide attempts
Suicide is the highest leading cause of death for people 15 to 29 years old
second highest among ages 15 to 34 and third highest among ages 10 to 14
There are many factors that increase the Likelihood of suicide
Here are the three most common factors
number 1. Major Depression
Major depression affects people both physically and psychologically
It can cause painful body aches and impairs the victims ability to see cognitive solutions
This distortion of cognition causes people who commit suicide to believe the world would be a better place without them
number 2. Loss of control
Impulsive tendencies leads to a lack of control resulting in maladaptive behaviors such as substance abuse
impulsivity breeds fear and anxiety which causes people to believe suicide is the only action they can take to put an end to
maladaptive thoughts or behaviors
Number 3. overwhelming regrets
most cultures believe that making a mistake is a sign of failure
Also, some people internalize their mistakes to the point of believing they're beyond forgiveness
This may cause them to believe the only reprimand that would bring justice to the act they committed is suicide
Many argue that suicide is a senseless act
But one's cognition has the ability to make sense of the most senseless things, especially if they have major depression or impulsivity
Prior to the Act of suicide there is a process of negative thoughts that manifest in physical and mental pain
The Act of suicide is seen as cathartic for people who suffer from guilt
Understanding that suicide makes sense to the suicidal person is an important step to getting them the help they need
One Major sign of Suicide is withdrawal
Withdrawal can be linked to one feeling shame for thinking about suicide or believing their feelings aren't being heard or acknowledged
reacting to the signs of suicide without stigma or shame could be the key to establishing a dialog with a
suicidal person and getting them the proper treatment